um dia todos os números da silva e sim
eu sei que a ser não mais como portugal
mas também a quem chama de mágico para
não ser talvez o olharam para a palavra
energia não é uma palavra tão pequena e
ao mesmo tempo consegue pensar em si um
conceito um poderoso clã luxo traz ecos
de ilusão fantasia e sonhos sonhos
pessoas com o meu mágicos consegue fazer
com que se materializem à frente de vós
sodes e é por isso que as pessoas gostam
tanto magia porque nos permite fazer
fugir à realidade permite sonhar
nessa hora é que o time precisa ao longo
dos anos em que faz magia energia é mais
cara aqui com um baralho de cartas como
este um bom jogo dedos e fazer assim um
feriado por exemplo ou então como
imagens que fazem programas uma carta
que 14 certo consegue ver possamos 14
estalando os dedos e temos um ganho ou
então com o tempo vamos ser difícil
podíamos nesta carta o psi que está
outra vez a questão é que é que eu tenho
preciso é mais do que isto na minha
opinião a energia é um ciclo que
considera que toda a gente deveria
aprender por pode facilmente abrir uma
nova visão nova expectativa sobre o
mundo ea minha forma de explicar isto é
quando é uma experiência com mágico
então responsável há muito muito tempo
não foi certo tempo mas é assim mil dos
7 um ano a us assim importa baixo o
chromium que tem sua hora mas sem barba
ok então eu droga livros de fantasia já
na altura ideal para iniciar dia lá na
minha escola em ansião por exemplo nós
queremos fazer aqui uma cirurgia após
alunos quanto gosta de harry potter
parece aceitar preenchidas engraçado e
tal eo meu nunca fez mal a ninguém e à
frente acentuada
não vai acontecer de culpa calmas é
calma olha mas nós vamos com uma cartola
e ensinamos truks 13 mineirinho vai ser
espetacular assim não vá se pacifique o
méxico e lá fui eu
no dia d para esse costume preparados e
vocês agora deve estar a pensar
foi sem dúvida este mágico não não foi
eu tinha quatro procurados na altura e
conseguiu falhar redondamente em 2 deus
hora imaginei um miúdo com pouca
confiança que acha que aconteceu ela por
água abaixo
e como foi dramatizado quebrando vários
anos eu não voltei por energia
oque aconteceu foi no 11º eu acho que é
uma série chamada aumentou está talvez
conheçam existe uma personagem patrick
ainda que é fascinante 51 mágico então
está sempre otimista com os as suas
capacidades para ajudar a polícia a
solucionar crimes só que da forma como
manda a constituição já é tal forma
carismática engraçada certo e olha pra
que eu pensei quando for grande quer ser
como tu lá fui eu então bm no computador
e fiz a pesquisa mais difícil da minha
vida
o google truques com cartas e eu em duas
horas dependendo do trânsito que
acontece lá vai usar na escola armado
como base cartas no bolso e chega lá e
faz magia 1 face a outros parceiros ea
outra e não estava à espera do convite
ano possa ser fácil fazer magia porque a
verdade é que ficava fascinado com a
possibilidade de que eu tinha de
controlar a situação e se tenha poder o
que aconteceu eu dei por mim a fazer
magia pessoas completamente aleatório
com um celular de um eo que acontece é
que o cm a fugir da minha zona de
conforto e quando eu fiz isso em geral
do comfort público e em pouco tempo cm
confiança aumentar imenso minha
confiança e outra coisa tem a capacidade
de improviso porque a verdade é que
começam a chegar lá e fazer um truque
acho que a posse da bola e wils conselho
por pessoa dentro da história isso é
fundamental então em pouco tempo
consegui aumentar as minhas capacidades
intelectuais imenso e é fantástico estar
a pensar muito bem então acho que aquela
experiência que há uns anos em falhar
redondamente câmeras mesmo entendimento
falharem contas à frente do álbum à
noite uma festa de ninguém não tem medo
de falhar certo é que a forma como nós
aprendemos a lidar com isso
falhar mas pode chover sem quantidade de
vezes que eu já fui na minha vida e que
são já perdi a conta
e nós acabamos com mágicos ganharam um
calo isso neste momento todos dar a
entender isso vamos contar uma história
daquilo que considero o meu melhor fui
anos com mágico
estava eu no meu primeiro ano de calouro
é que não foi a culpada
nós temos um evento chamado leilão do
calor as pessoas que lá acima
olha lá todos amam mas é ruim ter se
tornado a tecnologias o calor como é
óbvio que em cima sou mágico é pessoas e
sair fazendo assim na carta
pensar que um charme muito difícil um
erro
a dica do gênero imagens marcadas para
móvel que eu passei a fazer taça que
armar em bom
pela manhã já não descarta um pensar que
um dia eu acho que o momento se tivesse
um buraco com linguagens com ele estava
eu
assim o livro ter alguém da plateia a
imaginar primas da área que passou
pode botar após apostar em mim então
diga vou parar não quiser aqui pode ser
tão conversa carta certo podem ver certo
então essa carta é um prisioneiro fugir
da polícia e de um prédio que eu faço
pois dentro do prédio e ficar dentro de
casa entre por deus a fuga e eu achava
império hiperventilar pré sal tudo isso
então nós vamos ficar com as polícias
para nos ajudarem noé sentido e em pode
ser pode ser e fazer três e outro
polícia não sairá
olha assim vemos no brasil
avaliamos o prêmio extra gás todo olha
hoje destruído é ficar acordo as
polícias e numa das polícias ficaram com
a terceira carta à casa da pessoa que
aconteceu é como o grupo tem a plena
noção tem enganado ao fim já estava
então se um curso um corpo
acho que é uma visão cada moeda
entretanto ele um carrinho em seu e
agora faz assim
e esta é a nossa cara certo para ganhar
olha o que acontece é que ao contrário
do que acontecia há uns anos não
descarta fazer magia eo empréstimo com
uma lição em uma lição de humildade
concluiu que aprender o básico e
imprimir bom e admito isso e falei mais
investiram continuar essa energia e
viaja hoje em dia o nome que tem aqui na
faculdade mas é o mágico não se assustem
não quero pensar e energia edson da luz
aqui foi a da rodada se formos ao mundo
não é na minha opinião magia é conseguir
enganar suas com estilo e agora vamos
apresentar um amigo meu que é uma está
em faixa 2 estão de fato conhecimento
vai acontecer com a gente tá né
eu vou mandar um está em campanha e
quero que a pessoa que apanhava está em
jogo aqui no palco para eu poder ficar
uma das minhas ilusões costumo fazer
condenar pessoas podem ser quebrados
o jonas o troféu em não tenho medo não
mordo vejam lá é premium sai tão baixo
da camisa chegou a salvar almas com
nosso voluntário
um dia a dia mas são gonçalo estão com
falta desta pergunta agenda popular
chama mágico
a pergunta que se faz é porque chamam
maggi que não chama ilusionista faz
surgir mas também jesus ao cair na
escola que representa mágico ilusionista
em mas o que faz de crimes de índole se
estendendo é preciso é exatamente esse
mágico é porque nós temos algum tipo de
poder mágico o gol 1 0 as duas é só isto
qualquer pessoa consegue realmente eu
simplesmente sou melhor do que vocês
todos e vou provar que o nosso amigo
pode ser só olham por ser assim eu vou
passar cartas que quer ser campeão não
pode escolher por não pensar enquanto o
que me cai muito bem e vamos conversar
isso não tem nenhuma vir ao contrário e
vamos atrás do título tá aqui certeza
hoje irá acontecer nós neste momento
temos cartas estão viradas para cima e
cartas com viradas para baixo
eu quero que a primeira carta enviada
por baixo seja tocada
pode ser então é só daqui a 10 ou seja
pode ver pode ver o que acontece muitas
vezes energia imagem da foto é que pode
ver na carta no bolso taxa eu vou poder
ajudar o time
o plano à cabeça e que fecha os olhos e
que concentra o cara tá acontecendo por
lá lembra que a antena parabólica para
apanhar tá ok a equipe paulista cartão
isso como só tem tamanho nunca se sabe o
que vai fazer se opunha a operar já em
que a diferença de preço acontece em
doha no catar
era um sinal um carro ruim de resolver
tudo não é uma figura não expressa o
número é porque estou meio de câmeras
não às 12 34 5 634 77 pedras e dinâmica
bilionário funcionar hoje
não é assim é pra tanto obrigado a jogar
bem legal
olha como é óbvio a tensão imaginam
existir mas como podem ver eu conheci
cinco os truques de cartas e uma boa
dose no teatro eu consigo a cimentar a
nossa obsessão e 12 minutos até pensar
que o fato tem poderes para eu usar essa
capacidade com mágica que vai prender
uma lição muito importante que as regras
são mutáveis nem sempre um mais um é
igual a 2 e muitas vezes e consegui
fazer para vocês um mais um 6/3 e 11/9
esta capacidade e acaba por criar um
pensamento muito mais fora da caixa eu
consigo olhar problemas e olhar para
desafios disse que os sonhos e conseguir
ter uma perspectiva muito mais
periférica e eu acho isso muito
importante e não se salva
não existe meio jurista extremamente
famosa talvez não conheçam assim as
chamas natureza e quantas vezes não
acontece quando estamos no laboratório
com o treinado à experiência com os
resultados deviam dar exatamente aquilo
que quero exposto um circuito que
evitará a funcionar perfeitamente
a pressa natureza mágica faz uma obra
que elaboramos a volta de investimentos
em nós com margens chutamos mais alerta
que já estamos habituados a situações e
tentava isso eu não tenho capacidade de
resolver problemas é muito superior
antigamente eu juntei isto ocorre já que
fala aí e eu sinto que imaginamos na
forma como eu olho pro mundo e hoje nós
que somos um mundo mais proativa com
capacidade de gastar nas várias regiões
em que tem estado incluído e juntaram
com uma equipa a trabalhar juntos no
time trabalha com ninguém não teme ter
lugar num desafio lutar por ele e ir até
o fim até o fim e agora faço esta
pergunta quando vocês é que não tem
sonhos que estavam concretizados
quantos de vocês é que não tenha uma
idéia qualquer custavam de pôr em
prática
e quando você realmente tem a vontade
coragem de avançar com isso agora pensa
energia em opinião ajudou muito a 100
fora dessa caixa e numa altura em que
nós temos uma cidade tão competitivo
a magia sem dúvida como ajuda a primeira
a sair daqui está com êxito ao mundo lá
estou aqui estou aqui vai do bairro isso
é muito importante principalmente atesta
não gostar dessa terra
mas é uma opção que não fez aqui em
vocês vai para a energia eo crítico mas
como eu não gosto de desculpas neste
momento procurar aquilo que os magic não
gostam que é quebrado o fato nunca
ensinarmos um truque e agora vou mais a
itaboraí não tá ok eu queria já que
mandar só saem quando quiser ea pessoa
acompanhar juntos aqui no paulistão
despachou mais uma vez quando quiser mas
não mordem também não olha como vmware a
ensinar é outro que é muito especial
para mim porque é o primeiro truque que
eu aprendi quando você faz imagina falar
os voluntários
mas chama a equipe então foi morta no
dia 11 ao certo se é um então não fazer
agora é primeiro exemplifica o truque e
pois juntamente comigo vamos ensinar a
poder o que pode ser um simples
em uma carta que quiser fazer a carta
aponta agora quero dizer a carta ou não
não quiser quiser por michael volta dos
anos animados e vamos para dentro não
acontece o que aconteceu nada que me
impeça
eu quero ver os animais não tome quem
não quer
então não há ninguém a culpa em cima do
baralho
minha irmã estava escondida em contrário
à nossa espera de ver agora o ministro
acha que muito rapidamente vamos
princípio está no brasil certo é muito
fácil assim
na última carta do baralho e vemos o
caso contrário ele recuperar ou cair
exatamente as cartas sem qualquer uma
carta que ver com certo neste momento
pode estar a olhar pra cara tem uma
história à parte as mãos porque toda a
gente faz neste momento quando vocês vão
ver e ouvir eu era contrário exatamente
sem ninguém para não cair para a hora
neste meio tempo parado
jogamos na quarta fácil não é pré fácil
a carta fomos à casa aqui dentro eventos
uma história atenção histórias são
fundamentais
vamos aqui dentro neste momento nesta
quarta que mal correto
então nós fazemos é a banana e viramos o
contrário e quando vemos o contrário
iremos à casa do fundo
ao mesmo tempo estamos a pessoa ora as
pessoas adoram pensar milão mágicos
adoro então o que nós fazemos é nos
primeiro 15 segundos e depois
inventamos uma história seja magnetismo
seja as pinças vocês quiserem vamos aqui
em cima falamos desde lá mil
espero que no final desta tarde olhem
para a magia numa perspectiva diferente
notem que talvez um software que os
podem ajudar por um lado de ouvir nossa
capacidade mas também em cantar you e
quem sabe mudar o mundo e olha que os
diplomatas toda espécie de elemento que
cheguei logo à noite a casa peguei no
baralho e começa a fazer aquilo que já
faz há vários anos mas aí já espalhar
magia
obrigado